hello and welcome to this video and took
a bit of time here and yeah I had a
problem here take a technical problem
but it has been resolved okay so let's
see what we get against my way up late
night f6 here is playing this Queenie to
line yeah this has become fashionable
recently hmm i don't quite know how it
is played and this makes an awful lot of
sense a flat fee and catos now my setup
here is a bit passive quite clearly I
didn't want to play my usual line he
plays something strange against it which
I don't believe is good but I still have
issues with it so let's see what what
happens here okie dokie yeah I mean what
can always play something like five ok
it doesn't do it this is least this at
least weakens deform a little bit so
maybe I have some long-term ideas on
that square I'd like to play c5 and
Bishop to c6 night over and so on rugby
a the screen a formatting the bit
inconvenient
so what can you do I was thinking Queen
a 4 C 5 critics a seven bishops e6 that
threatens to trap the Queen and threaten
c4 okay plays this yeah he's a very
ambitious enterprising player and this
is an interesting choice I can't go d5
technically I think
takes takes Knight takes Knight takes
bishop takes Bishop age three you should
be good on look do you want to have 25
for the background made no let's see
what happens you can of Bishop h3 can
play Bishop g2 I can take 25 and take c5
so I think it should be it should be
rather ok ok so my way what are you
going to do you can also play a other
move say of course some group g1 on
moves that keep the tension but I'm
attacking c5 so it's not like you can
play anything hmm ok possible yeah of
course well I mean here i can i can play
age 60 just play for them and ok i
cannot take c5 later i have d 4 here
how interesting okay let's let's do this
and here I'm going to play okay I cannot
remove to it were three books a hero and
I do this first and then take on c5 that
gives me a nice activity
yeah just clean the two areas or queen a
form i know i can take be too maybe yeah
so i take be too and he takes c6 or what
that cannot be all that great what's
happening here Bishop c5 he goes what
Queen a phone and I da phone Roxy true I
don't know do I want to take this or not
i think i will do that i will take it is
it going looks know this one yeah i
thought i should be ok here as c6 and
they to look rather weak rather weak
then strong but maybe i'm not assessing
it correctly just not quite sure at
least rupee one is not possible ok here
this I can take check and cover and I
want to go look a five rupee one is
impossible my bishop on a5 is doing a
good job here yeah the sound is strange
I don't know what that is it sounds a
little bit weird so
what are you doing now my way
Derek's it to us i think what i'm going
to play next what is this idea okay i'm
going to play in any way so let's do it
ruki to i can take that ending is just
wins my king is picking up stuff okay
I'm rook a 2mm should should work rocky
for I have 55
rook we won Jake's rupee seven still
still annoying him hmm I wonder could I
have avoided that somehow I don't really
see him if I could have done that time
morning hmm doesn't look like it's
enough damn what did I do okay wait wait
I can do this and rugby three
potentially this is interesting yeah
yeah yeah that's better that's a lot
better I win the bishop ending easily
because the paths will just fall and I
have time now for King is seven and then
I can pick up those pawns I think slowly
yeah fix that on dark squares so nothing
will happen and now i can let me let me
check bishop t5 yeah it's a pot so let's
do it check
white forfeits on time so does someone
we had I don't know what it is it's kind
of noisy yeah anyway um we had an
interesting game yeah I think that yeah
I don't like the opening here my my d6
is certainly not the way to do it
Queenie to is a funky idea that came up
recently because why doesn't really have
any success with with the regular lines
with e5 and yeah I know it looks funny
but ultimately g3 Bishop g2 is kind of a
logical setup so okay i went with with
this again that's not the best setup
ever but at least it's kind of its kind
of solid so quincy to be aid the dog is
kind of normal i think i know you went
45 this is interesting yeah well okay
taking us out of the question i think
this is just too ugly and why it has
chances to push his pawns maybe not
immediately but in the near future so i
think this should be the principal
reaction my development is not that bad
i mean all pieces are playing somehow
okay played here and now they're here
this is a very tough situation i can
also maybe go here I mean I thought
about this but I wasn't quite sure how
to continue here this looks a little bit
isolated on d4 I wasn't sure if I get
enough support for this pawn yeah in the
system yeah that it seemed logical to me
and to do this and now ed5 this Bishop
f5 yeah the computer agrees I think I've
found
right moves here yeah Queen a4 I was
expecting this move which is given as
roughly equal by the engine I'm not sure
that I would have played see takes 25 I
was thinking about this now hair
computer likes this pollution roughly
equal access again I got very active
piece of CM for the for the pawn yeah
Queen a for now the engine wants to play
Bishop d3 aware that makes quite some
sensor I didn't look at that tempo and
if I get to take fc5 i have f to under
attack hmm that's a very good move
something like or here you know that's
all well it's already winning yeah well
we cannot move the rock then the engine
wants to do this and take here with the
th for black Oh interesting no I didn't
see that I just felt that this is a kid
won't be 2 a.m. okay that was my train
of thought okay this this and this and
okay well okay the engine gives me a
slight edge but the other probably was
stronger yeah the advantage that black
hairs it's not great but those pawns are
easier to attack than my opponents and
yeah i think the rook trade also helped
me g4 going back okay to be one yeah
okay the computer is smooth it as as
usual it was to take and now give us out
yeah I wasn't sure about the remaining
low so what is the computers line I mean
okay it's always checking this is of
course important
yeah it might win it might win the idea
rook takes a for rupee 7 this kind of
thing is also not bad but I think my
solution is good it just gets
counterplay to a minimum and and tier
I'm winning very easily probably should
not trade rooks but rather play look you
won or something but again I can detect
this probably a 5 look before just just
take the pawn and pick it up later lamb
that should be it should be enough to
win okay guys I hope you enjoyed the
video thanks for watching